President Trump has already called the
opioid abuse epidemic a crisis today the
administration brought together a wide
array of people determined to do
something about it
correspondent Kevin cork has more
tonight from the White House
we're with you 100% we're fighting for
you and we're gonna win we're gonna win
at this afternoon's White House opioid
summit president Trump made it
abundantly clear as fights go this one
is only in the first round and if you
want to be weak and you want to talk
about just blue ribbon committees that's
not the answer the answer is you have to
have strength and you have to have
toughness the gathering a follow-up to
last October when the president declared
the crisis a nationwide public health
emergency as Americans we cannot allow
this to continue it's time to liberate
our communities from the scourge of drug
addiction since then the White House has
embarked on a comprehensive plan to
tackle the problem education and
prevention treatment and recovery and
law enforcement and interdiction the
latter of which produced the Justice
Department's first-ever indictments
against Chinese fentanyl manufacturers
and a national take back day that saw a
record 456 tons of expired and unneeded
prescription drugs collected critics
have accused the administration of doing
little to change the lives of those
impacted with dnc spokesman Daniel
Wessel writing actions speak a lot
louder than words with people's lives on
the line each day
Trump's actions say he does not take
this crisis seriously indeed to some the
opioid battle is also a political one
the crisis has had a disproportionate
impact on rural America and often
overlooked part of the electorate that
helps propel the president into office
or in the case of states like New
Hampshire and Minnesota nearly did where
you have the highest levels of abuse is
exactly where his Forgotten men and
women live so you know they're going to
say yes you know good for my man Donald
he's paying attention to the problems my
neighbors have for context in 2016
president Trump lost New Hampshire by
fewer than 3,000 votes and actually came
within a percentage and a half of
winning Minnesota a state that last went
red
back in 1972 Brett
Kevin cork in the White House briefing
room Kevin thanks